bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regardant
direct notre grand témoin ce soir c'est
le journalisme et écrivain Mathieu Palin
qui signe aux arènes une enquête
absolument édifiante nos pères nos
frères nos amis dans la tête des hommes
violents fruits de 4 années de travail
sur ces hommes qui frappent leur femme
c'est un texte important il fait froid
dans le dos et pour une fois c'est un
homme qui s'empare de ces sujets les
violences faites aux femmes on va en
parler on est ensemble pendant une heure
pour décrypter l'actualité de ce
mercredi 25 janvier au sommaire ce soir
un an après le scandale hors pa qu'est
ce qui a changé l'implacable en quête de
Victor castanel et fossoyeur fut un
électrochoc
sous-effectif maltraitance rationnement
la gestion des EHPAD a-t-elle évolué à
ton fait des progrès et quelle loi
faudrait-il voter pour bien vieillir
dans notre pays c'est notre grand débat
ce soir dans un instant avec nos invités
avant de retrouver à 20h15 les parties
pris de nos affranchis et le bourbon
Express bien sûr l'histoire du jour
rassembler Mathieu Penin vous êtes prêt
ça vous regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
on a tous en mémoire la déflagration il
y a un an le scandale hors pa éclaté à
la faveur de la parution d'un livre qui
choquait la France entière des résidents
privés de soins éléments terre le
rationnement sur les couches les repas
pour maximiser les profits et un système
généraliser de détournement d'argent
public un an après qu'est-ce qui a
changé les problèmes ont-ils disparu à
ton fait des progrès bonsoir Astrid
panozian Bouvet merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes députés renaissance de Paris
et c'est vous qui portez la proposition
de loi qui sera discutée à l'Assemblée
au printemps prochain après les
retraites c'est possible de penser après
retraite et on est modestement
coordonner la rédaction et c'est une
proposition doit sur le Bien vieillir
ensemble c'est l'expression consacrée
bonsoir Jérôme Guedj merci d'être là
député socialiste de l'Essonne grand
spécialiste des questions liées au grand
âge vous avez publié des livres et des
rapports sur le sujet bonsoir Laurent
Garcia bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes le président de l'Observatoire
du grand âge et vous êtes le tout
premier lanceur d'alerte à l'origine des
fossoyeurs de Victor Castanet c'est
simple sans vous bah il y a pas ce livre
puisque vous étiez cet ancien cadre
infirmier des bords de Seine on se
souvient c'est le nom de l'établissement
privé horea à Neuilly-sur-Seine vous
nous en parlerez enfin bonsoir Pascal
Champvert bonsoir grande figure de ces
questions aussi depuis beaucoup d'années
vous êtes le président de l'ADPA
l'Association des Directeurs au service
des personnes âgées merci à tous les
quatre je suis sur Matthieu Palin que ce
débat vous intéresse vous avez un
grand-père je crois que j'ai un grand
père de 96 ans qui vit encore chez lui
mais
forcément à cet âge là on se dit que la
dépendance est possible donc c'est le
débat de société qui touche au cœur de
toutes les familles françaises on va
planter le décor pour commencer
j'appelle mon camarade des complices
Stéphane blackowski 200 secondes pour
nous dire ce qui a changé le pari voilà
il est élevé on l'accueille tout de
suite le chrono de Blacko
les femmes et on se retourne pour vous
accueillir bonsoir à toutes et à tous du
haut de cette estrade alors pour
commencer Myriam Randon à Victor ce qui
appartient à Victor car si je suis ce
soir sur cet estrade pour lancer un
débat sur la situation dans les EHPAD
c'est grâce à lui il s'appelle Victor
Castanet il a 35 ans l'an dernier
quasiment un an jour pour jour il
publiait les fosses flyers donc cette
enquête qui révélait les méthodes du
groupe privé hors pa dans la gestion de
ces 350 et pas de en France donc vous le
disiez tout le monde s'en souvient a
priori surtout sur ce plateau mais le
livre avait fait un peu l'effet d'une
bombe donc j'ai trouvé une image pour un
peu illustrer l'impact de la
déflagration vous vous rendiez compte
des dégâts que ça a causé attention
âmes sensibles s'abstenir
et ouais ça c'est le décrochage de
l'action ORPEA vous voyez du moment le
bouquin a été publié et ça ne s'est pas
vraiment arrangé par la suite donc on
imagine bien que 30% des EHPAD en France
est en main de groupe privé les gars ont
quand même du sentir passer le volume le
vent du boulet donc il y a sans doute
une prise de conscience c'est ce que
pense Victor Castanet qui était ce matin
sur France Inter on l'écoute le secteur
a pris conscience de l'ampleur de la
crise et du lien de confiance qui
s'était rompu à la fois avec les
familles et avec les soignants les
salariés de ce secteur et que donc si ce
secteur notamment la partie lucrative
veut survivre à cette crise il va
falloir qu'elle change en profondeur
alors après un scandale pareil on se
pose toujours la même question mais bon
sang mais que fait le gouvernement mais
c'est pas possible donc le gouvernement
ne peut pas rester les bras croisés
quand il fait depuis un an il a une idée
qui est pas mauvaise après tout de
lancer une inspection dans les 7500 et
pas de France donc très bonne initiative
Kevin sauf que en fait pour l'instant
cette année 20% des EHPAD ont été
inspectés il en reste donc 80 inspecté
si on veut respecter le contrat aïe aïe
aïe je suis désolé mais je vais être
vulgaire dès qu'on parle des situations
les EHPAD on arrive au nord de la guerre
l'argent tout ça une question d'argent
faut pas imaginer des aides soignants
sadiques qui se serait infiltrés non
rien à voir si il y a de la maltraitance
dans les EHPAD c'est parce qu'on manque
de personnel et clair Guédon rapport
défenseuse des droits ou défenseurs on
va dire des droits l'explique très bien
on écoute
si vous n'avez pas suffisamment de
personnels te faites vous êtes
maltraitant quand vous demandez une
aide-soignante de faire 15 toilettes en
deux heures mais de fait elle devient
maltraitante malgré elle et c'est bien
pour ça qu'il y a des difficultés de
recrutement les aides-soignantes elles
vont revenir elles le distribment si
elle savent qu'elles n'auront justement
plus qu'un squelette à faire en deux
heures bon voilà je suis désolé on va en
revenir une question d'argent comment on
fait pour embaucher des gens ça coûte de
l'argent donc elle l'a fait FHF
c'est-à-dire la Fédération hospitalière
de France les hôpitaux publics eux ils
disent faudrait 100 000 emplois nouveaux
dans les EHPAD d'ici 2030 le
gouvernement dit bon peut-être que 50
000 en 2027 ça serait déjà pas mal on
comprend que le gouvernement est des
soucis tout ça il y a plein de budgets
mais en même temps l'année prochaine il
y a seulement 3000 emplois
supplémentaires prévus dans les EHPAD
donc on se retourne vers le président
Macron on dit Monsieur c'est pas
possible sauf que regardez il fait des
très belles photos Emmanuel Macron quand
il visite les EHPAD montrer sa proximité
avec les anciens sauf que bon il avait
prévu une loi sur le grand âge en 2018
elle a été abandonnée manque d'argent il
en avait prévu une autre en 2021 elle a
été abandonnée aussi donc j'espère que
celle de 2023 aura plus de succès mais
je n'aime pas la câbler parce que on
définitive c'était pareil pour François
Hollande avant lui il faisait de très
belles photos lui aussi dans les EHPAD
promesse 18 de son programme une grande
réforme sur les dépendances mais quand
on n'a pas d'argent on réforme pas la
dépendance et pour rendre hommage
Nicolas Sarkozy qui faisait les mêmes
photos que tout le monde on dira que il
était le premier en quelque sorte à dire
attention faudrait faire quelque chose
pour la dépendance avant que la crise de
2008 le fasse dire non on n'a pas
d'argent on le fera pas donc je vais
vous laisser débattre juste avant une
illustre beaucoup moins jolie un petit
papier un peu dégueulasse mais en fait
c'est le chiffre qu'il faut retenir il
tissu d'un rapport écrit par quelqu'un
qui s'appelle Dominique Libourne ancien
directeur de la Sécu qui nous dit que en
fait il faudrait dépenser 6 milliards de
plus par an à partir de 2024 et 9
milliards de plus par an d'ici à partir
de 2030 pour régler les problèmes des
états donc je vais vous laisser débattre
mais il est question de milliards à
trouver donc j'espère que vous penserez
nous dire où vous trouvez tous ces
milliards pour aider nos anciens 9
milliards par an il faut se figurer les
choses à partir de 2030 merci beaucoup
le décor est planté on va on va venir à
ce qu'il faudrait faire c'est un sujet
complexe mais j'aurais déjà qu'on parle
d'orpa parce que ce scandalisé les
Français c'est ce qui s'est passé dans
ce très très grand établissement privé
départ déjà Laurent Garcia vous qui est
passé par ORPEA on a entendu ce matin la
nouvelle direction d'orpa sur France
Info nous dire que tolérance zéro sur
les pratiques illégales une trentaine de
personnes ont été mises à la porte
d'ailleurs pour faute grave il y a la
justice qui est qui est saisie est-ce
que tous les éléments les plus
dysfonctionnels de repa sont terminés
est-ce que le système ORPEA c'est fini
alors je peux pas vous dire oui ou non
ce qui est sûr c'est que moi j'ai des
salariés d'Orpea qui m'appellent encore
et qui sont toujours en souffrance donc
le système est peut-être terminé ce
système mafieux je pense que je pense
qu'il est terminé après
ORPEA quand même à continuer à
travailler avec quelques fournisseurs
qu'ils avaient auparavant et avec qui
détournaient de l'argent public c'est
fournisseurs sont toujours là
Bourdin qui a été remercié de chez ORPEA
et quand même encore des directeurs
générales du groupe bastide
qui a fournisseur de matériel
pour bien comprendre c'est un système de
surfacturation qui a été condamné avec
des fournisseurs et vous nous dites
qu'ils sont toujours en lien commerciaux
avec leur père de fournisseurs qui sont
toujours en lien avec le groupe hors pa
donc que tout a changé je ne crois pas
corps pa soit dans une situation
difficile j'en suis certain
mais voilà j'attends de voir
les excédents de dotation il y a eu
d'autres d'autres établissements qui ont
été pointés du doigt ce système hors pa
faut bien expliquer peut-être parce
qu'elles sont vers c'était l'idée que on
a une enveloppe négociée avec la Région
le Département et elle peut pas bouger
c'est ça et donc les fournisseurs en
surfacturant en faisant des par exemple
des couches ou des produits de santé
plus élevés pouvaient se voilà les
établissements pouvaient s'enrichir sur
ça en gros c'est ça il faut bien voir
que ce qui a très bien décrit l'an
dernier Victor Castanet c'est un système
de cupides et de malhonnête bon
juste un mot là-dessus ce système aussi
dysfonctionnel il n'a été possible
pendant tant d'années que parce que
l'ensemble du système des établissements
mais aussi des services à domicile
l'ensemble du système des personnes
âgées dysfonctionnent si on était dans
un système qui fonctionnait correctement
la malhonnêteté la cupidité la
restriction sur tous les moyens pour les
personnes âgées que ce soit
l'alimentation que ce soit le temps
passé auprès des personnes âgées dans un
système qui fonctionnerait ça se serait
vu tout de suite pourquoi le système
hors paix est la plus fonctionné si
longtemps parce que tout le monde sait
en France que quand on vit dans un
établissement comme le dit clairon on
n'a pas suffisamment de professionnels
qui passent du temps auprès de vous et
c'est la même chose à domicile non mais
je m'éloigne pas c'est parce que le
système dysfonctionne globalement que
des malhonnêtes ont tourné
système est détourner de l'argent
pour pour bien comprendre parce que
toujours sur ORPEA aujourd'hui il y a
cette nouvelle édition chez gélules de
Victor Castanet qui montre aussi comment
ce journaliste d'investigation a été
intimidé Jérôme Guedj par toute une
série de choses des cabinets de conseils
par des commandes de sondages par des
établissements des pâtes privés Korian
ORPEA qui se cachait derrière voilà des
parfois même il y a deux types de
sondages des sondages réels et puis des
sondages truqués plateau de Cyril
Hanouna tout ça ça vous surprend ou pas
non ça me surprend pas parce que on est
sur des activités qui malheureusement
sont devenus tellement financiarisés
c'est-à-dire que le centre de gravité de
l'activité même c'est déplacé de la
qualité de la prise en charge sur
laquelle il peut y avoir des acteurs
privés enfin il y a plein d'acteurs
privés dans le pays il y a des cliniques
privées il y a des entreprises privées
dans des marchés publics etc mais là le
centre de gravité c'était déplacé avec
des gens qui se sont dit bah tiens on
peut gagner beaucoup d'argent et donc il
y a eu un système je sais pas si on peut
le qualifier de mafieux mais en tous les
cas dans lequel il y a des gens qui sont
dit on a beaucoup d'argent à gagner là
et donc là où il y a beaucoup d'argent
mais après on essaye de de préserver ça
et donc on est dans les batailles
d'influences de lobbying de fake news de
désinformation pour essayer de
sauvegarder une image parce qu'on voit
bien que on est sur des acteurs que pour
lesquels l'image l'image compte donc
derrière ça se pose la question de
savoir si c'est légitime d'avoir des
acteurs n'ont pas privé mais des acteurs
quels qu'ils soient qui pouvaient
fonctionner sans garde-fou et le vrai
problème il est là et l'absence de
garde-fou je prolonge ce que dit Pascal
c'est que quand on est dans un secteur
dans laquelle dans lequel
malheureusement on est tous quand je dis
on c'est nous la société française
responsable d'avoir organisé une
insuffisance de moyens qu'on a décidé de
donner bah on veut pas aller contrôler
forcément des acteurs parce que on va
forcément exciter les difficultés qui
sont celles de tous les EHPAD qui soient
publics associatifs ou privés qui est
que la collectivité nationale ne donne
pas suffisamment de moyens donc ceci
explique un peu cela c'est c'est le
prolongement de la crise hors pair mais
pour terminer sur ORPEA actuellement il
y a des gens qui veulent nettoyer les
écuries de Jas j'espère que ils le font
avec avec rigueur il faut d'abord qu'il
solde l'argent qui a été détourné ils
ont mis un peu de temps à rembourser et
à débattre y compris du montant des
choses qui a été détournées et puis moi
il y a un point sur lequel j'attire
notre attention collectivement c'est
l'État a porté plainte des collectivités
des départements ont porté plainte qui
est bien un moment il va falloir aussi
que la justice passe donc depuis un an
il y a des procédures judiciaires qui
sont ouvertes mais je constate que pour
l'instant elles n'ont pas encore abouti
on est on a commencé à documenter à
partir du travail de Victor Castanet des
inspections qui ont été faites mais à un
moment il faudra bien aussi que la
justice passe parce que c'est une caisse
de résonance dans le débat dans le débat
public et aussi de manière de dire que
des gens doivent être sanctionnés il
peut pas y avoir des unités elle prend
elle prend du temps dans notre pays
dernier élément nouveau dans l'enquête
de Victor Castanet puis ensuite on
arrive sur ce qu'il faudrait faire ce
sont ces élus alors il y a Jean-Louis
Borloz qui était épinglé dans le livre
qui je dis aurait prévenu Korian c'est
ce qui affirme Victor Castanet lui
dément et puis il y a cette députée de
la majorité à Street panosiane Bouvet à
nividal qui signe une tribune dans la
presse juste après le scandale pour
réclamer une commission d'enquête à
l'Assemblée ses collègues dans la
majorité la critique pour ne pas dire le
fond de pression sur elle pour que et
bien cette commission n'est pas lui
écouter là j'ai considéré que je devais
signer cette tribune que je pouvais
signer cette tribune parce que j'étais
convaincue que c'était le meilleur moyen
pour faire pour aller chercher la vérité
certains de mes collègues m'ont
effectivement envoyé des messages me
disant que
ma signature était inopportune que je ne
rendais pas service aux candidat Macron
et que à ce titre je n'avais plus ma
place dans le groupe moi je ne pense pas
que cette commission aurait fait du tort
à Emmanuel Macron cette commission
aurait eu pour moi l'avantage de faire
éclater la vérité et faire éclater la
vérité c'est toujours profitable à un
président de la République voilà des
propos recueillis et par Marco pommiers
Astrid panneau Jean pouvait vous qui
venez d'arriver à l'Assemblée depuis
2017 depuis 2022 pardon comment vous
réagissez depuis 2022 on dit souvent que
le courage c'est la première des vertus
mais quelle est la moins partagée et
voilà moi je veux saluer
malgré toutes les intimidations dont
effectivement il témoigne dans cette
nouvelle édition je veux je veux saluer
le courage de Laurent Garcia et des
salariés qui parfois le risque est péril
ou parfois sont revenus sur des
histoires anciennes qui dont il
n'arrivaient pas à sortir et qu'ils
faisaient souffrir et je saluer elle
avait toute sa vie le courage d'anniv
Vidal qui
a demandé une commission d'enquête parce
que c'est ce qu'il faut il faut pas
avoir peur de la vérité à partir du
moment où on commence à avoir peur de la
vérité c'est mauvais signe à la fois
pour une institution pour une
organisation et là effectivement on a
besoin
politiquement mais même en tant que
société de savoir clairement ça a été
rendu possible quand elle dit au fond ça
n'aurait pas forcément déstabiliser le
président candidat à l'époque bien au
contraire elle avait totalement en
raison est-ce qu'on a besoin de savoir
précisément comment cela était possible
et en tirer les enseignements alors je
voudrais qu'on les entendent ces
familles et puis je vous donne la parole
juste après témoignage qui montre bien
qu'il reste beaucoup à faire y compris
dans les ehpads publics Isabelle
jardilier témoignent des conditions dans
lesquelles avec eux sa mère c'était la
veille de la sortie des fossoyeurs il y
a un an en janvier 2022 elle alertait
l'agence régionale de santé et dénoncée
un système de maltraitance Verbatim
signée Hélène Bonduelle
en plaçant Janine 84 ans on n'est pas
dans 2016
Isabelle n'imaginait pas que sa mère
vivrait un calvaire au quotidien
pour la première chose qu'elle a vécu
très très difficilement c'est de n'avoir
qu'une douche par semaine et ça c'est
sur le papier parce que plusieurs fois
j'ai dû intervenir puisque rester 15
jours sans douche la deuxième chose
qu'elle a très très mal vécu c'était
l'obligation de porter des protections
que le personnel appelle couche moi ce
qui me ce qui me choque ce terme choc
personnellement donc elle est obligée
d'en porter la nuit parce qu'il n'y
avait pas cette personnel pour pour
venir l'accompagner aux toilettes moi
j'appelle ça de la maltraitance
ordinaire je mets des guillemets à cet
ordinaire là parce que c'est tout sauf
ordinaire mais c'est de la maltraitance
quotidienne quoi oui
des repas mal adaptés des douleurs non
traitées pendant des mois un manque de
soin isabelle n'a cessé d'alerter la
direction quand je faisais remonter les
choses dans un premier temps la
situation pouvait s'améliorer pour ma
mère mais c'était les améliorations
étaient toujours de très très courte
durée et je savais pertinemment que si
ça s'améliorait pour elle ça se
détériorer pour d'autres
parce que il y avait pas assez de
personnel pour s'occuper de l'ensemble
des résidents des résidents un manque de
personnel criant dans cet EHPAD public
du centre de la France alors quand le
scandale horpa éclate il y a un an
Isabelle qui vient de signaler à l'ARS
les conditions de soins de sa mère n'est
pas étonnée
je me suis dit en fait c'est pas mieux
dans le public mais on en parle pas
parce qu'on imagine pas qu'il y a cette
maltraitance
ordinaire il y a une véritable une
véritable atteinte au droit fondamentaux
des personnes âgées
Janine confie même à sa fille avoir
l'impression d'être en prison d'être
abandonné ma mère a plusieurs reprises
me disaient elle se plaignait puis elle
me disait dit rien dit rien parce que ça
va me retomber dessus voilà il y a
vraiment une peur et des résidents des
résidentes et des familles d'ailleurs le
personnel avait interdiction de parler
aux familles
janine est décédé le 10 novembre dernier
la veille la RS était enfin venue
inspecter l'établissement
isabelle a porté plainte pour
maltraitance auprès du Procureur de la
République et elle continue de se battre
aux côtés d'un collectif qui milite pour
vieillir dans la dignité on nous parle
cette fameuse loi de fin de vie les bons
mourir dans la dignité c'est bien mais
je pense qu'il faut commencer par
vieillir dans la dignité donc il faut
des moyens
[Musique]
alors les moyens d'abord comment comment
on peut les trouver dans ce quinquennat
parce qu'elles sont ouverts est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord pour dire que ça y
est tout le secteur et dans la prise de
conscience d'ailleurs qui a une forme de
rupture avec les familles on le voit et
avec les acteurs les soignants dans les
établissements et qui va falloir réparer
vous qu'est-ce que vous attendez
précisément
de Victor Castanet moi vous savez ça
fait 35 ans que je travaille dans les
établissements les services à domicile
pour personnes âgées ça fait 35 ans que
je dénonce le manque de personnel et pas
moi tout seul avec l'association que je
préside la débat mais aussi avec
l'ensemble des organisations
professionnelles tout à l'heure on a
parlé de la Fédération hospitalière de
France donc nous nous découvrons rien
c'est maltraitant ce quotidien nous les
connaissons mais nous avons fait
paraître l'an dernier une plateforme
disant arrêtons de maltraiter les
personnes âgées et les professionnels
qui les accompagnent ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que pendant des années
nous étions nous-mêmes maltraitée par
les pouvoirs publics je me souviens d'un
des responsables de la débat auquel un
responsable de département a dit écoutez
vos histoires de qualité vous gardez ça
pour vos colocs ici on parle de choses
sérieuses c'est-à-dire de finances donc
nous n'avons pas les moyens de vous
donner les finances que vous demandez
donc vous ne les aurez pas donc vous
bossez et vous arrêtez vous
plaisanteries c'est c'est comme ça que
depuis des années des années les
pouvoirs publics états et départements
ont toujours réglé la situation du
manque de moyens c'est en demandant à
des professionnels de s'adapter à des
situations dans lequel la variable
la variable d'ajustement ça a toujours
été la qualité de vie des personnes
âgées le premier responsable c'est les
pouvoirs les tailles et les départements
et je dirais les présidents de la
République on aurait pu parler de
Jacques Chirac il était président du
temps de la canicule il avait eu un
discours fort ensuite Nicolas Sarkozy
ensuite François Hollande ensuite
Emmanuel Macron le problème de fond
c'est qu'ils ne sont ni les uns ni les
autres jamais aller au bout de leurs
organes c'était toujours la dernière des
priorités c'est ça que ça raconte la vie
juste un mot là-dessus c'est la
discrimination par l'âge et dans une
société agiste c'est toujours le dossier
après tous les autres il y a toujours
quelque chose de plus important et ça
boutit à la situation qu'on connaît
maintenant
déjà les contrôles parce que pour
pouvoir voilà employer de ramener des
effectifs rendre attractif il faut voir
ce qui se passe
l'État les moyens de ces contrôles on
voit que on en est même pas à la moitié
des établissements contrôlés aujourd'hui
je veux quand même dire une chose dire
que les chocs d'émotion ils ont pas
commencé avec cette affaire avec
l'affaire Cassani enfin faut se rappeler
du choc autour de la canicule en 2003 il
faut se rappeler du choc de la première
vague covid aussi qui a marqué et les
familles et les professionnels de santé
donc donc oui moi je souscris à ce mais
malgré tout
les moyens qu'on n'a pas d'abord qu'on a
peut-être pas voulu voir
voilà qu'on a pas voulu voir et c'est
vrai qu'en France aussi on a fait ce
choix et vous qui travaillez dans le
domicile mais par rapport à d'autres
pays et notamment de pays d'or du Nord
un choix plutôt aussi d'hébergement en
EHPAD plutôt que le choix du domicile
qui est pourtant le choix absolument
plébiscité par les familles tant que
c'est possible donc il y a un sujet
aussi collectif je pense à un moment
donné un choix de société de ne pas
vouloir voir les problèmes qui fâchent
et donc ça va passer par des contrôles
naturellement et on va il y a des
engagements il y a des choses qui ont
été prises monsieur Combes disait
aujourd'hui qu'il y avait 400 contrôles
qui avaient été fait alors qu'on veut et
que l'objectif c'est d'arriver à un
contrôle tous les deux ans bon en
Allemagne ils ont un contrôle tous les
ans donc ça veut dire qu'on peut faire
mieux mais c'est vrai qu'on part de 20
ans voire de 7 ans tous les 7 ans donc
oui mais c'est pas suffisant c'est à
dire que c'est pas simplement par le
contrôle il faut mettre en en place un
véritable processus d'amélioration
continue avec la sanction derrière mais
aussi avec effectivement des moyens qui
permettent une meilleure taux
d'encadrement et puis des choses qu'il
faut aussi sanctuariser dans le droit je
pense qu'une des choses qui sont
remontées régulièrement auprès de la
Défenseur des droits c'est la question
du droit de visite ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui faut rétablir dans
dans la loi préciser le rôle de la
personne de confiance sous le sens que
le droit de visite existe il n'est pas
garanti
pour cent des remontées faites à la
Défenseur des droits c'était sur le
droit de visite donc cette proposition
de loi dont madame d'ailleurs un ividal
sera rapporteur avec Madame monikibora
elle va sanctuariser ce droit de visite
comme elle va préciser le rôle de la
personne de confiance c'est certainement
pas la solution à tout je suis pas en
train de dire que c'est la solution il
nous faut une loi grand âge mais en
attendant on essaie de répondre à
quelques sujets du quotidien donc il y a
ces sujets là et les indicateurs
qualités pour pouvoir aussi faire du
libre choix autour des indicateurs
qualités il y a une plateforme qui
signale les maltraitance aussi
exactement qui a été mise en place par
le gouvernement Jérôme Guedj vous ça
fait des années que vous dites qu'il va
falloir trouver des dizaines de
milliards on était à 10 milliards en
gros par an à l'horizon 2030
où on les trouve jusqu'à présent aucun
gouvernement de droite comme de gauche
ne les a trouvées et ne s'est lancé dans
cette réforme pour les raisons rappeler
Pascal Champvert c'est que il y a
cette agisme l'attend dans la société
c'est pour ça que moi je pense c'est une
responsabilité collective de la société
dont l'État et les collectivités locales
sont d'une certaine manière le le bras
armé puisque c'est eux qui a un moment
donné bon sauf qu'il y a des moments où
il faut que les on soit l'avant-garde
éclairés et qu'on soit capable de
prendre les bonnes les bonnes décisions
et ce qui est très paradoxal Astrid le
rappeler au gré des différentes crises
la canicule le covid ou l'affaire hors
pair il y a pardon se prurit émotionnel
et après c'est business à jouer ça
retombe je vous prends qu'un seul
exemple ce qu'on parlait des contrôles
et puis il y en avait un autre c'était
sur le budget journalier par rapport
elle annonce 10 critères elle fait un
communiqué de presse la ministre et ben
le 31 décembre dernier le décret enfin
l'arrêter prend des critères et n'en
prend que 5 qui sont allez on va dire
très homéopathique c'est la superficie
des chambres savoir s'il y a un lit ou
de lit savoir si on peut bénéficier de
l'aide sociale dans les départs dans le
dans l'établissement c'est-à-dire que on
a cette émotion et et franchement et
parce que il y a cette mais je pense et
que c'est parce que si on mettait ces
critères en transparence on mesurait le
cœur du problème qui est celui dont il
faut parler qui est qu'à un moment donné
on n'échappera pas à dégager des moyens
financiers dans notre société et tout ça
est consensuel le rapport Libeau en
effet il a dit 6 milliards alors bien
sûr c'est des sommes qui font peur mais
derrière c'est pas de l'argent pour les
personnes âgées c'est de l'argent pour
créer des emplois et uniquement des
emplois des emplois dans les territoires
des emplois en zone rurale des emplois
de liens social à domicile et tout le
monde accepte et encore une fois ça fait
plaisir on a le consensus sur le
diagnostic et là où il y a un désaccord
sur lequel tout le monde s'est fracassé
c'est d'aller chercher 6 ou 9 milliards
d'euros c'est même la Cour des comptes
qui est pas un repère de gauchiste il
habitude dit faut baisser la dépense
publique même là ils disent maintenant
il faut l'augmenter d'un milliard par an
et on le fait pas dans le dernier PLFSS
on a fait la moitié du chemin c'est bien
je prends mais à un moment donné il va
falloir aller chercher l'argent et c'est
le partage c'est la solidarité c'est la
sécurité sociale de l'intérieur si on
avait ces milliards et si on arrivait à
rendre attractif à nouveau ses emplois
parce qu'aujourd'hui personne ne peut
recruter
en ce moment en ce moment le véritable
fossoyeur c'est l'état c'est pas le
livre de Victor Castanet c'est l'état
parce que que fait l'état à l'heure
actuelle il fait le Conseil national de
la refondation la fabrique du Bien
vieillir en fait on donne nos arrangé
aux associations aux familles et au
total on fait rien entre 2018 2022 7
rapports plus de plusieurs centaines de
préconisations et les temps n'en tient
pas compte le véritable fossoyeur à
l'heure actuelle c'est l'état et ne fait
rien et quant à contrôlé quelque chose
qui va mal ben oui ça ira mal forcément
venez contrôler n'importe quelle EHPAD
ça va mal et obligé des salariés à
mettre des croix dans des cases au lieu
de s'occuper des résidents et ben ça
peut pas fonctionner non plus donc oui
on est en colère là on est en colère
parce que j'ai l'impression et je vais
être vulgaire on se fout littéralement
de notre gueule en fait on en est là on
se moque de nous que faire alors des
contrôles la RS va nous contrôler la RS
nous finance aussi comment financeur
peut nous contrôler une autorité à
vérifier
les EHPAD il le faut le président m'a
dit non d'abord le contrôleur et le
contrôler il y a un petit problème c'est
les ARS qui contrôlent alors qu'elle
finance on le sait avec le département
c'est un problème ça alors moi j'entends
la proposition de Laurent Garcia d'avoir
un contrôleur dédié comme les instances
les endroits pris de privés de
privatives de liberté et j'entends ce
sujet de conflits d'intérêt potentiels
entre le contrôleur le contrôle et moi
ce que je souhaite d'abord c'est qui est
des contrôles réguliers une efficacité
du contrôle qui soit suivie de résultats
voilà c'est ça que je souhaite et et le
fait qu'on veuille aujourd'hui augmenter
ses contrôles voilà avec une fréquence
tous les deux ans c'est une bonne chose
mais encore faut-il que ce regard
faut-il encore faut-il que ce soit suivi
de résultats et moi là et moi ce que je
veux dire je veux dire c'est
pas les contrôles qui vont suffire c'est
exactement ce que je suis en qu'est-ce
que vous dire qu'est-ce que vous
répondez
vraiment l'État le fossoyeur
l'expression est forte et on sent
vraiment presque la collection de la
colère de la part de Laurent Garcia et
il a raison d'être en colère enfin il
est lanceur d'alerte de ce de cet
ouvrage qui a permis aussi de prendre
conscience en tout cas dans l'opinion
publique de ce qui se passait il a
raison d'être en colère et je pense
qu'on des constat ici et pas mal de
députés également de la majorité qui va
falloir un moment donné dégager des
moyens voilà il y a un consensus autour
de ces 10 milliards tels qui sont
aujourd'hui un moment donné il était
même question que la réforme des
retraites puisse financer c'était non
c'était évoqué il faut là on va pas
revenir sur les retraites dépendants
objectifs c'est plutôt le financement
des systèmes de retraite et de la
pérennisation mais il y a un vrai sujet
autour de dégager des recettes
aujourd'hui pour financer le grand âge
voilà c'est un vrai sujet de
gouvernement c'est qu'elle au moment où
je vous parle quand même
combe est avec Sarah Selmane sur le TPMP
moi je suis désolé ça m'inquiète en fait
ça me manquait c'est hyper inquiétant on
en est là à l'heure actuelle le
gouvernement ne fait rien ne fait rien
nous vend rien il ne fait pas que rien
il y a quand même eu de l'argent en
mission la table avec le Ségur qui a pu
aussi bénéficier au personnel de l'Ehpad
non mais ça fait quand même en terme de
salaire net mais ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas assez d’abord parce que ça concerne
pas l'ensemble des personnes travaillant
à domicile pour le secteur lucratif et
ensuite parce qu'il y a eu un parce que
ce sera pas suffisant aujourd'hui de
taux d'encadrement de recrutement de
valorisation de ces métiers
d'attractivité justement pour terminer
ce débat qui s'achève mais comment on
revaloriser aujourd'hui que le salaire
pense c'est suffisant revenir du
personnel soignant dans les EHPAD il
n'est plus attractif ce métier sur la
faire des contrôles parce que entendez
ce que le regard SIA et moi qui sommes
des professeurs de terrain vous disons
il y a dans la proposition de loi que
sur laquelle vous travaillez plein de
choses extrêmement intéressantes pour
améliorer la citoyenneté et comme vous
l'avez dit des choses au quotidien et
nous et nous travaillerons avec vous
pour pour enrichir ces propositions il
faut vous compreniez madame la députée
monsieur le député que les contrôles
comme le dit Laurent Garcia dans un
secteur qui dysfonctionne ça ne
débouchera sur rien
non non la nuance c'est la suivante
c'est que ça ne débouchera sur rien et
en attendant ça donne du travail
supplémentaire à tous les professionnels
ça veut dire que les infirmières les
aides-soignants les cadres de santé au
lieu de passer du temps auprès des
personnes âgées ils vont remplir des
documents dans le cadre du contrôle donc
les contrôles ça va à l'inverse de ce
qu'il faut faire quand on aura le 8 pour
10 que manifestement vous prenez tous
les deux que demande la Défenseur des
droits à ce moment-là quand on aura des
moyens comme nos voisins européens que
vous parlementaire que des inspections
indépendantes viennent nous contrôler ça
ce sera normal
10 personnes âgées et 30 euros de
financement pour les services à domicile
tant qu'on aura pas ça c'est-à-dire tant
qu'on a pas les moyens de fonctionner je
voudrais que vous compreniez Mesdames et
Messieurs les parlementaires que vous
nous donnez du boulot en plus et que
donc ça accroît les difficultés côté du
secteur le contrôle c'est pas un pas en
avance c'est un pas en arrière il faut
avantage la question c'est quand elle
est toujours pas l'ordre du jour et elle
est et la vraie question c'est celle des
moyens on l'a déjà dit et dans cette
société si on décide il y a des
priorités budgétaires et mon problème il
est là ce n'est pas la priorité
budgétaire en tous les cas du mandat du
mandat en cours parce qu'on est capable
de baisser des impôts pour certaines
catégories de la population et de pas
utiliser l'argent qu'on aurait pu garder
pour financer cette réforme des
retraites c'est un vrai choix politique
et un choix de société merci beaucoup on
verra si cette loi grand âge est au
rendez-vous de ce quinquennat ce dernier
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron verra et
on vous réinvitera à ce moment-là bien
évidemment merci pour vos analyses alors
vous avez été assez timide Mathieu Palin
mais j'ai pas eu le temps
dans une dizaine de minutes on va
retrouver nos affranchis pour leur
partie prix vous les voyez ils sont
enfin prêts en coulisse le regard de
Richard vernis sur l'Europe quoi la
livraison des Charlots au Ukrainiens ici
stratégiques les histoires d'écoles de
Yanis roder plaidoyer pour un
enseignement laïque du fait religieux et
puis Bourbon Express l'histoire du jour
à l'Assemblée une histoire de temps de
parole sur les retraites mais d'abord on
se plonge avec vous dans la tête des
hommes violents c'est une enquête je le
disais qui est glaçante vous nous faites
entendre une parole très rare celle des
bourreaux celle qui n'arrivent pas à
dire tout simplement je frappe je frappe
ma femme et on va comprendre pourquoi
ces quatre ans de travail dans des
groupes de parole on voit tout cela
juste après l'invitation de tiboenok
si on vous invite Mathieu Palin c'est
que 220 000 femmes au moins sont
violentées chaque année par leur
conjoint et que de ce chiffre vous avez
tiré une dérangeante équation 220
000 victimes se sont 220 000 bourreaux
220 000 hommes violents qui nous
entourent des hommes qui sont nos pères
nos frères nos amis comme le titre votre
dernier livre les hommes comme les
autres et pourtant différents et que
vous avez tenté de comprendre Mathieu
Palin vous êtes journaliste et écrivain
après vous être longtemps rêvé
professeur de PS vous avez troqué le
jogging basket des cités de l'Essonne où
vous avez grandi pour la plume avec
laquelle vous avez conquis le Tout-Paris
dès votre deuxième roman en 2021 vous
obtenez le Prix Interallié pour
l'histoire de Toumani Coulibaly sprinter
français à la double vie de cambrioleurs
que vous allez rencontrer pendant deux
ans en prison la question que je venais
chercher moi en allant rencontrer
Toumani c'était pourquoi un mec aussi
talentueux a tout gâché un peu comme
dans un roman d'Agatha Christie on
cherche le coupable et les êtres humains
sont en général un peu plus complexes et
des coupables il y en a plusieurs cette
fascination pour l'origine du mal et le
premier point commun entre vos livres le
second et cette envie d'aller à la
rencontre de l'autre de faire entendre
sa voix pour votre dernier ouvrage vous
vous êtes donc rendu pendant 4 ans dans
des groupes de paroles rassemblant des
auteurs de violences conjugales vous en
rapportez des propos glaçants dès le
début un point vous frappe le déni est
tel que plutôt que de dire je frappe ma
femme on trouve un milliard de
justification pour pour justement ne pas
le dire ce déni Mathieu Palin vous vous
en rendez compte repose aussi sur le
fait que ces hommes estiment leur
agression légitime
elle m'a provoqué elle parle mal elle
n'avait pas fait à manger elle cherche
le contact physique pour pouvoir dire
ensuite qu'elle s'est fait taper dessus
des hommes qui se vivent comme des
victimes donc et qui ont souvent un
problème constatez-vous avec la
masculinité je vais te montrer c'est
quoi un homme j'ai voulu montrer que
c'était moi le plus fort et j'ai gagné
un complexe de domination mise à mal qui
se retrouve en miroir dans l'image
qu'ils ont des femmes depuis qu'elles
ont le droit de vote le droit de porter
des mini jupes on a plus aucun droit
nous les hommes si tu donnes trop de
liberté à ta femme c'est pas bon
pourtant les psychologues que vous
interrogez l'affirme la rédemption est
possible elle arrive quand le langage
parvient à remplacer les coûts alors
Mathieu Palin une question pour finir
vous qui avez écouté tous ces hommes
qu'est-ce qui vous en distingue où se
situe-t-elle cette origine du mal
réponse Mathieu Palin qu'est-ce qui me
distingue de ces hommes j'ai envie de
répondre pas grand chose en fait ce que
j'ai réalisé en étant sur place avec eux
en passant du temps avec eux parce que
c'est des groupes de paroles il y en a
certains qui ont duré plus de six mois
c'est qu'en fait on avait plus ou moins
suivi les mêmes voies pour en se disant
devenir un homme c'est ça et il y a le
rapport du Haut Conseil pour l'égalité
qui est sorti cette semaine nationale
contre le sexisme aujourd'hui on en dira
un mot et quand j'étais un œil j'ai
reconnu beaucoup de de finalement de
conclusion que j'avais eu au contact de
ces hommes là c'est à dire que la
violence et la violence dans le couple
elle est aussi liée à l'incapacité pour
les mecs pour les hommes de parler de
régler un conflit autrement par que par
les points de voir l'autre non pas comme
son égal mais comme un adversaire comme
quelqu'un qu'on doit dominer et ça je
pense que très masculin et très dans des
clichés stéréotypes de genre et dans les
clichés que vous avez c'est énorme à 23%
des hommes entre 25 et 34 ans c'est
l'enquête que vous que vous mentionnez
celle du Haut Conseil à l'égalité
considère qu'il faut parfois être
violent pour se faire respecter vous
l'avez constaté vous chez les plus
jeunes hommes finalement dans la
jeunesse une espèce de d'un
supportabilité de l'émancipation de la
femme finalement
les gonzesses elles vont prendre notre
place c'est ça qui vous disent il y
avait ce discours là qui était je pense
très lié au mouvement Mitou aussi parce
que c'est une micro partie du problème
les hommes que j'ai rencontrés sont des
hommes qui ont été condamnés par la
justice qui déjà font partie d'exception
parce que l'immense majorité des hommes
violents ne rencontrent pas la justice
seulement une femme sur cinq qui portent
plainte et toutes les plantes
n'aboutissent pas à une condamnation
donc ces hommes là se sentaient vraiment
victimes le mouvement mondial qui les
dépasse presque comme s'ils avaient une
sorte de gros nuage noir au dessus de la
tête qui serait le mouvement MiTo et
une forme d'agression complètement et
ils lisent leur condamnation
comme étant la preuve d'un retournement
de la situation des femmes qui sont
maintenant au pouvoir et qui l'utilisent
pour se venger et ça cette distorsion de
la réalité elle était très très forte
décrivez-nous un petit peu
l'atmosphère on n'est pas du tout chez
les alcooliques anonymes comme son
épaules moi c'est ce que je pensais
aussi je pense à arriver dans un groupe
avec 12 personnes à 6 ans en cercle et
comme chacun commence en se disant
bonjour je m'appelle Mathieu j'ai 34 ans
et je frappe ma femme et c'était un peu
un fantasme de journaliste d'aller
là-bas et d'entendre cette phrase que
j'avais l'impression d'avoir jamais
entendu et
en fonction de qui aussi sélectionner
dans le groupe puisque ce sont des
hommes qui sont suivis par la justice et
des profils ce qui c'est ce qu'on
appelle ce que les animatrices
appelaient des leaders négatifs le
premier qui parle et qui dit moi j'ai
rien à faire là je suis pas comme vous
de manière ma femme c'est une menteuse
et et je devrais pas être là je suis
victime d'une erreur judiciaire il lance
il donne un peu le la et là on a un
effet de groupe avec des mecs derrière
qui vont dire mais moi non plus j'ai
rien à faire là et puis de toute manière
les femmes ont repris le pouvoir et je
sais que dans certains groupes ça se
passe pas comme ça je sais que dans
certains groupes il y a des le premier
qui parle dit
j'ai été condamné deux fois j'aimerais
m'en sortir je sais pas pourquoi je
répète sans cesse c'est même c'est même
passage à l'axe cette même violence et
là ça donne autre chose ce qu'il faut
dire et l'enquête le montre bien parce
que vous vous mettez en scène aussi vous
racontez vos proches c'est que ça peut
être tout le monde c'est loin d'être des
monstres ce sont nos pères nos frères et
nos amis
vous avez parlé à vos proches vous en
parler avec votre compagne avec votre
cerf et avec votre mère et vous
découvrez quelque chose qu'elle ne vous
avait jamais dit non qu'elle avait
jamais dit à personne d'ailleurs en fait
le tout début de cette enquête c'est
d'avoir le constat que je suis
journaliste je suis un homme et ça fait
10 ans que je travaille et que j'ai
jamais écrit une seule ligne sur la
question des violences faites aux femmes
que ce soit le harcèlement le le vieux
et quand le mouvement me too est arrivé
et que toutes ces femmes ont dit moi
aussi j'ai vécu une agression moi aussi
je me suis dit est-ce que vraiment c'est
un mouvement d'ampleur à ce niveau là et
donc j'ai appelé ma mère et elle m'a
confié d'avoir elle m'a dit non moi
j'étais institutrice donc en fait dans
un milieu plutôt féminin j'ai pas eu à
faire à la domination des hommes et puis
après elle m'a rappelé en me disant en
fait il m'est revenu une histoire et on
venait fait elle avait été agressée à 17
ans par le père de famille chez elle
faisait du baby-sitting qui avait essayé
de la violer
elle elle me disait je sais pas comment
j'ai réussi à m'en sortir mais c'est
vrai et c'était quelque chose qu'elle
avait jamais raconté
dans tous ces témoignages la même forme
de déni systématique c'est-à-dire au
fond c'est pas moi
pas je suis la victime systématiquement
est-ce que à la faveur des psy que vous
avez rencontré dans ces groupes de
paroles la rédemption est possible
comment on arrive à basculer vers les
mots et sortir de cette emprisonnement
mental qui fait qu'on n'arrive pas du
tout à se vivre autrement que comme une
victime et un mot qu'on prononce
maintenant que ça ce qui est le mot
déconstruction je pense que c'est un mot
qui est important parce que c'est vrai
que certains de ces hommes arrivent dans
le groupe ils ont déjà 60 ou 65 ans
il paraît plus que compliqué de se dire
bon maintenant en fait tout ce que vous
avez appris jusqu'à présent tous vos
comportements tout ce que vous avez
accumulé et puis l'histoire de vos
parents et ce modèle
ultra viril qui était celui de votre
père tout ça maintenant vous le mettez à
la poubelle et vous essayez de changer
c'est compliqué c'est extrêmement
compliqué c'est pour ça que
les la justice essaye de se focaliser
maintenant dans ces groupes de parole
sur des jeunes qui sont déjà passés à
l'acte des jeunes de 18 19 ans il y en a
malheureusement
et des jeunes parents qui qui peut-être
vont changer en sachant que eux-mêmes
sont à ont eu ce comportement violent
parce que aussi ils ont eu un père
violent et peut-être que là en regardant
leurs enfants qui ont trois quatre cinq
six ans peuvent se dire il faut que je
change parce que j'ai pas envie que ma
fille aussi se retrouve dans cette
situation j'ai pas envie que mon fils se
retrouve dans cette situation donc c'est
possible parce que c'est peut-être
possible les psychologues que vous a
interrogés restent optimistes qui est
intéressant aussi c'est le rapport à la
mer chez ces détenus ou anciens détenus
pour pour violences conjugale on est
vraiment dans un schéma la maman et la
en gros la mère qui m'a nourri
intouchable et la femme avec qui je vis
elle mérite les coûts on en est encore
là pour certains en tout cas c'est
Liliane d'aligand qui est une experte
psychiatre experte auprès de la Cour
d'appel de Lyon qui a expertisé plus de
700 violents qui repèrent des des
similitudes dans certains comportements
et qui dit que en fait le
le manipulateur pervers narcissique qui
jouit de sa violence et du mal qu'il
fait il existe mais elle en a pas
rencontré beaucoup par contre des
immatures qui voient leur femme comme
étant toujours en compte en comparaison
avec leur propre mère et donc leur mère
une demi DS il pourrait tout faire pour
elle il pourrait tuer il pourrait être
et leur femme qui fait jamais assez bien
qui est toujours à la traîne bon ce ce
rapport là d'adversité c'est quelque
chose qu'elle a beaucoup observé et
c'est pour ça qu'elle parle d'immaturité
chez ces hommes violents d'incapacité à
régler un conflit autrement que par la
violence il vous a changé vous-même
Mathieu balance ce livre vous dites au
fond je me suis intéressé à des sujets
masculins jusqu'à présent c'est vrai que
vous êtes en T par la question de la
prison la question de l'ambiguïté aussi
du mal avec on se souvient
coulibalyse coureur qui a passé beaucoup
d'années en prison mais qui apparemment
va et il va reprendre le sport mais
ça vous a bouleversé ça vous a traversé
vos personnellement qu'est-ce que vous
en tirez vous à titre personnel de tous
ces témoignages en passant beaucoup de
temps sur le terrain j'ai réalisé que
finalement la violence conjugale et pas
toujours cette autre qui nous ne
ressemble pas qui est moins intelligent
que nous moins éduqué un peu plus bas de
plafond et qui frappe sa femme
simplement parce que il sait pas quoi
faire et qui rentre du boulot et que il
a il a toujours fait ça peut être le
voisin le boulanger sans parler le
patron et d'ailleurs c'est ce que je
ressentais sur le terrain et puis quand
on regarde les chiffres on voit que ce
sont on n'a pas 500 ou 700 ou 800 000 ou
1 million de monstres dans ce pays et
les chiffres sont assez éloquents 220
000 vous utilisez ce chiffre ça fait 220
000 le chiffre
de ce qu'on a repéré sachant qu'il y a
un chiffre noir qui est qui est
probablement quatre fois plus important
que celui-là et ça peut être parfois
on va terminer avec cette image Adrien
Catena si vous le savez qui a réintégré
son siège de député à l'Assemblée
nationale qui ne siège plus dans la
France insoumise qui a été condamné pour
violence conjugale vous trouvez que la
manière dont les partis politiques
gèrent ces sujets de violences sexuelles
et sexistes est à la hauteur où il y a
encore beaucoup de boulot il y a
beaucoup de boulot déjà parce que je
l'ai entendu sur BFM TV tenter de se
défendre et je reconnaissais exactement
les mêmes paroles que les hommes qui
étaient assez autour de moi
avec cette idée de puissance financière
aussi tout ce que j'ai payé pour c'est
beaucoup des choses que j'ai entendues
et bon la différence c'est que les
hommes avec qui j'ai passé beaucoup de
temps sont pas élus de la République
donc le devoir d'exemplarité ils l'ont
pas ils essayent déjà de gérer leur
propre vie là on a quelqu'un qui a été
condamné à une petite peine avec sursis
qui ne l'a pas encore fait et qui a
réintégré le moi je suis pas mon avis
compte
n'engage que moi donc c'est que ça à mon
avis mais c'est vrai que sur ces
questions là on a besoin d'avancer et de
tous collectivement se ressentir
concerné et ça commence aussi bien
entendu par les politiques et ça
s'appelle nos paires nos frères nos amis
dans la tête des hommes violents voilà
ça ne laisse pas indemne et c'est
extrêmement bien écrit je le conseille à
tout ça les fait-leur d'accueillir nos
affranchis pour leur partie prix on les
accueille tout de suite rentrer les amis
Richard Verly
installé vous allez nous parler ce soir
des livraisons des chars les fameux
charlés par deux en Ukraine les chats
allemands mais aussi américains et
britanniques et puis Yanis roder bonsoir
vous êtes notre enseignant dans cette
émission membre audio conseil sur la
laïcité vous allez vous parler du
ferludieux on enseigne très peu dans nos
établissements laïques mais on commence
comme chaque soir par Bourbon Express
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée nous
est racontée par Elsa mondingava une
histoire de temps de parole sur les
retraites exactement je vais vous poser
une question presque philosophique 73
heures de débats sont-elles suffisantes
pour discuter d'une réforme des
retraites je vous donne pas 73 heures
pour y réfléchir on va essayer de faire
ça en quelques minutes alors ce matin la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale Yaël
brune Pivet l'adressait ses vœux à la
presse elle la redit pour rassurer il y
aura du temps pour débattre ici à
l'Assemblée il y en aura même plus que
pour les précédentes réforme des
retraites écoutez
nous sommes à
73 heures de séance versus 2014 45
heures et versus 2010 65 heures nous
aurons le temps de débattre et mon
objectif effectivement en tant que
président de l'Assemblée nationale c'est
que nous allions au bout du texte
maintenant à nouveau si nous devions pas
avoir de vote ce serait en toute
probabilité parce qu'il y aurait de
l'obstruction donc je n'en serais pas
responsable ni le gouvernement
évidemment alors elle a raison la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale sauf
que à l'époque en 2010 en 2014 la
situation n'était pas du tout du tout la
même je vous parle d'une époque où il y
avait que la droite et la gauche à
l'Assemblée allait un peu de centriste
un peu de communiste mais en 2010 la
droite elle avait la majorité absolue
2014 c'était la gauche et donc c'est
donc des réformes qui ont été adoptées
beaucoup plus facilement voilà donc
l'argument du moment du gouvernement en
deux temps il y a 73 heures c'est
beaucoup et si à la fin on n'a pas le
temps de voter ce sera la faute des
oppositions puisque je vous le rappelle
en ayant choisi un projet une boîte
finances rectificative il y a des délais
contraints 50 jours en tout 20 jours en
première lecture à l'Assemblée vendredi
17 à minuit que le texte soit fini ou
pas il part au Sénat alors quelle est la
stratégie de l'opposition la Nupe a
promis un mur d'amendement c'est
toujours le cas ou pas alors ça tombe
bien justement parce que cet après-midi
place du Palais Bourbon juste devant
l'Assemblée nationale il y avait un
point presse des syndicats il y avait
Laurent Berger de la CFDT il y avait
Philippe Martinez de la CGT mais nous et
bien on sait chercher surtout des
députés de gauche on en a trouvé
évidemment dans les parages depuis
plusieurs jours il semble s'interroger
sur la bonne méthode sur leur stratégie
bah on leur a posé la question
est-ce que vous vous voulez aller
jusqu'au vote jusqu'au vote final et
compter clairement ceux qui sont pour
ceux qui sont contre à l'Assemblée en
tout cas on veut que le débat ait lieu
sur le point clé qui est l'article 7 et
l'article 7 c'est de la rallongement de
deux ans et on veut pas que le
gouvernement utilise le faible temps de
parole pour ne pas pouvoir discuter du
coeur de la réforme qui est de la
Contre-Réforme qui est cet article 7 sur
le report de deux ans vous vous ne ferez
pas d'obstruction il y aura pas
d'obstruction il y aura une opposition
très ferme mais qui doit permettre
d'examiner le cœur de la réforme qui est
cet article 7 sur le reportage vous
l'avez entendu la gauche elle va se
concentrer sur l'article majeur le 7 le
report de l'âge légal de 62 à 64 ans
quitte à finalement et bien retiré les
amendements avant faire avancer le débat
le plus possible ils veulent un vote
là-dessus ils ne veulent pas forcément
un vote sur tout le texte c'est assez
subtil écouter pierre darriville un
député communiste la majorité vous dit
si vous voulez en vote et bien c'est
entre vos mains
on verra comment les choses se déroulent
mais d'abord moi ce que je demande c'est
le retrait du texte vous voyez on est
loin du vote pour l'instant est-ce que
la gauche
qu'elle pourrait perdre et le
gouvernement dirait bah voilà cette
réforme elle est passée à l'Assemblée on
dirait que vous faites tout pour
finalement ne pas aller jusqu'au vote ce
texte est légitime donc on pense qu'il
faut le retirer c'est d'ailleurs ce que
demande les organisations syndicales et
moi depuis le début c'est ce que je dis
ça n'est pas sérieux d'aller à un texte
avec toutes les organisations syndicales
qui sont opposées 15 à 30% d'opinion
favorables dans les enquêtes c'est pas
sérieux voilà on comprend que la gauche
elle veut faire durer le débat ici à
l'Assemblée pour faire durer la
contestation là-bas dans la rue le but
pour l'instant c'est pas que le test
soit rejeté c'est qu'il soit retiré par
le gouvernement sous la pression de
l'opinion publique évidemment on va
suivre ça de très près sur elle CP ce
feuilleton des retraites Richard
livraison de chars léopard 2 par
l'Allemagne à l'Ukraine c'était un long
suspense ça y est c'est en fin décidé ça
peut tout changer ou pas forcément sur
le front alors vous connaissez peut-être
Myriam la formule terrible du général
américain McArthur lorsqu'il commandait
les forces durant la guerre de Corée il
disait que les règles guerres au fond se
résume à quatre mots trop peu trop tard
et bien cet anniversaire de la guerre du
Corée il est intéressant c'est le 27
juillet 1953 que la péninsule s'est
retrouvée divisée vous savez l'exemple
il est souvent cité faut juste rappeler
que le long de la zone des militarisées
aujourd'hui encore 70 ans plus tard il y
a énormément de troupes américaines mais
revenons d'abord au trop peu parce que
de quoi parle-t-on on parle de 14
charléopard une trentaine de chars M1
Abrahams probablement plusieurs dizaines
d'autres chars en provenance d'autres
pays européens au total une centaine
est-ce que cela peut faire vraiment la
différence face à l'armée russe qui ne
l'oublions pas c'est de plus en plus
solidement retranché alors c'est quand
même peu probable on est plus vers une
consolidation des lignes actuelles et à
partir du moment là se pose une question
est-ce que garantir aux Ukrainiens du
matériel lourd ce n'est pas au fond
surtout dissuader les Russes de tenter
eux de repartir à l'offensive
c'est-à-dire figer la situation
vous êtes plutôt pessimiste trop peu
vous avez dit et trop tard aussi
pourquoi il faut poser la question parce
que cela fait des mois que l'Ukraine
réclame ce matériel lourd et ses blindé
alors pourquoi avoir attendu le premier
anniversaire du conflit on y arrive ce
sera rappelons-le le 24 février alors on
connaît les difficultés du chancelier
allemand scholls avec son propre parti
le Parti social-démocrate qui est encore
très pacifiste au sein de sa coït
coalition on sait aussi que les
gouvernements européens attendaient
l'hiver ils redoutait les coupures
énergétiques bref on a quand même
l'impression que ce calendrier de
livraison des léopards il ne répond pas
seulement à une logique militaire on
note aussi qu'Emmanuel Macron n'y a pas
encore ajouté les chars français Leclerc
on sait que le commandant chef américain
Marc millénarrête pas de dire que
l'Ukraine ne pourra sans doute pas
regagner les terrains perdus on peut
donc se poser la question les Léopards
les challengers les Abrams tout cela
est-ce que ce n'est pas avant tout pour
servir de bouclier et donc quelque part
sauver la face vous le voyez plutôt en
défensif qu'en offensif bon on enchaîne
autant nous écouter Yanis histoire
d'école vous revenez d'un cours
particulier que vous avez donné à des
élèves de terminale vous leur avez parlé
d'origine de l'antisémitisme mais vous
avez constaté que alors en matière de
fait religieux personne ne connaît rien
alors bon c'est pas en réalité je suis
pas surpris Myriam j'ai des élèves tous
les jours en face de moi et c'est vrai
que le balai élève ne savent
généralement pas que Jésus était juif
que l'évangile selon saint Jean c'est un
passage du Nouveau Testament ou encore
que le prophète de l'islam Mahomet est
le saut des professionnels c'est-à-dire
celui qui sait la prophétie c'est un
problème franchement personnellement je
ne savais pas tout ça non plus alors
deux choses me posent problème en
réalité Myriam la première c'est que
sans la culture religieuse à ne pas
confondre avec la croyance sans la
culture religieuse donc beaucoup de
choses dans la culture mais aussi de ce
que disent les religions nous échappent
connaître c'est se donner les moyens
d'analyser de comprendre mais aussi de
ne pas essentialiser
la deuxième raison Myriam c'est
l'absence de réponse de l'institution
scolaire en réalité et ça c'est un peu
la résine en 2002 vous aviez déjà le
rapport de Brie qui insistait sur la
nécessité d'un enseignement des faits
religieux rien n'a été mis en place si
ce n'est l'étude historique de la
naissance des trois monothéistes mais
sans s'intéresser ni aux messages ni aux
ambitions de ceci et en 2018 le Conseil
des Sages de la laïcité produisait une
note sur la nécessité de cet
enseignement elle est consultable sur le
site du Conseil des Sages où elle dort
tranquillement sans être dérangé par
personne alors qu'est-ce que vous
préconisez c'est-à-dire enseigner le
fait religieux comment précisément sans
enseigner la pratique religieuse c'est
cela en fait Myriam il faut un
enseignement laïque défaire religieux
qui offrirait une culture commune et
partagée tout en posant un regard
scientifique sur les religions avec la
mise en perspective qui est nécessaire
au delà il permettrait d'outiler les
enseignants pour faire face au
contestations des enseignements au nom
des croyances enfin cela éviterait que
le doute s'installe parfois dans des
esprits adolescents qui ne comprennent
pas par exemple à un des limites mais
qui sans explication si vous voulez
peuvent finir par se dire aider par des
gens malveillants que bon il y a pas de
fumée sans feu si vous voulez et bien
non il n'y a pas de raison objective à
la haine antisémite mais il y a une
longue construction historique qui est
allée donc à chercher à aller chercher
du côté de l'histoire des religions
comprendre les phénomènes c'est se
donner les moyens de les combattre vous
avez fait de l'histoire des régions ou
du fait religieux à l'école ou pas du
tout ça manque c'est vrai que ça
permettrait déjà de mieux comprendre
l'autre déjà la haine oui c'est aussi la
méconnaissance de l'autre bon écoutez on
verra ce que ça donne on va retrouver le
rapport du Haut Conseil de la laïcité
qui est remisée dans un dans un tiroir
merci des affranchis merci aussi d'avoir
été concis et merci elles annondagaba à
demain si vous le voulez bien très belle
soirée sur LCP lisez nos frères nos
pères nos amis dans le bon ordre c'est
aux arènes et c'est signé Mathieu Palin
très belle soirée à demain
[Musique]